écoutez moi bien les chinois vont gagner
cette guerre
ils vont gagner cette guerre contre la
montre en trois mois mais il faut vous h
et à quel prix vous devez c'est un
signal d'alarmé lancé par ce médecin ses
compatriotes français de café les pleins
qui a été au coeur de la crise de
lakovic 19 en chine au cours des
derniers mois donc médecin chef de la
clinique internationale de yuans en
chine
on le retrouve en direct ce matin
docteur klein bonjour bonjour mais
d'abord ça fait deux mois que vous menez
vous le combat contre les coronavirus en
chine personnellement le 60 jours à
prendre soin de vos patients elle ne pas
avoir pu voir votre femme vos enfants
quand vous regardez ce qui se passe
ailleurs dans le monde que ce soit en
france aux états unis en italie gérées
même ici au canada
est ce qu'on fait ce qu'il faut selon
votre expérience lui a coûté pour
l'instant je suis absolument
catastrophique elle catastrophique déjà
parce que nous sommes trois mois après
le début de cette épidémie et j'ai
l'impression que peu de leçons ont été
tirées de ce qui a été fait ici en chine
et en asie
il y a maintenant des leçons à tirer il
faut les tirs et le plus rapidement
possible nous avons la leçon
sud-coréenne des sud coréens ont utilisé
des tests ils ont testé un maximum de
personnes ce qui doit perdre leur a
permis d'isoler les patients positifs et
de et de les confiner de les suivre
éventuellement par gps
nous avons l'exemple japonais les
japonais à partir des clusters ont fait
des enquêtes extrêmement rigoureuses
pour isoler tous les patients et
maîtriser l'épidémie
et puis nous avons l'exemple chinois la
chine a essayé le la quarantaine à
partir du 23 janvier au bout de trois
semaines elle s'est rendu compte que
cette quarantaine ou aux mails laisser
une certaine liberté aux personnes ne
fonctionnait pas et à partir de la mi
février
elle a pris des mesures absolument
drastiques pour arrêter cette épidémie
ces mesures drastiques elles ont
consisté à faire un confinement strict
total de la population sur 56 millions
de personnes tout arrêter tout arrêté
uniquement concernés de conserver les
industries l'italie prioritaires arrêter
les transports et pendant que cette
population était fij
il n'y avait plus aucun brassage des
mouvements de virus cette possibilité de
transmettre le virus
faire une caractérisation de toutes les
personnes positives pour les sortir de
la population saine et les soigner ou
les confiner dans des dans des salles
d'expositions dans les stades et les
sujets contacts dans des hôtels
et c'est à ce prix que en quatre
semaines et bien l'épidémie aujourd'hui
il est terminée en chine
est-ce que vous ne deviez de père classe
matin que les mesures qu'on voit
d'isolement ou de confinement mais
partielle ce n'est pas suffisant donc ça
passe vraiment par des mesures radicales
pour pouvoir vaincre le virus ça ne
fonctionnera pas nous avons maintenant
l'exemple chinois et nous avons aussi
l'exemple italien
les experts chinois sont arrivés à rome
est la première chose qu'ils ont dit ces
arrêtés les transports arrêtez ce
brassage de populations vous entretenez
vous entretenez l'ailé les contacts
interhumains et vous entretenez
l'épidémie les gens continuent à ceux à
ceux à se donner le virus est ce que ça
dépend du nombre de cas quand on a dans
chaque pays où vous êtes
tout le monde devrait faire ça ça dépend
du nombre d'autres le cas que l'on à
dents dans un pays en effet si vous avez
peu de cas alors à ce moment là
appliquant la méthode sud-coréenne
faisons des tests un maximum de
personnes et probablement qu'on peut
maîtriser assez rapidement l'épidémie
[Musique]
maintenant si on est dépassé par les
événements ou que l'on n'a pas assez de
test alors là de façon inéluctable je
pense qu'on évolue vers une situation où
l'on doit confiner les personnes
arrêtées les brassages et caractérisé
chaque patient il existe une dernière
solution ce serait celle d'avoir un
traitement
malheureusement à ce jour ce virus n'a
pas de traitement aucun système
immunitaire me connaissent eux ce virus
on sent vraiment votre inquiète c'est
dès ce matin la terre plein bien sûr une
inquiétude ça fait trois mois que nous
luttons ici je pensais que la chine
avait gagné le pari de protéger le reste
du monde
elle a protégé la chine continentale
mais malheureusement le virus s'est
répandu en une pandémie sur le reste de
la planète
on aime en famille est en france je suis
inquiet pour l'ensemble de la place
je suis inquiet pour la promo pays je
suis inquiet pour ma famille et être moi
quels sont les risques pour le personnel
soignant parce qu'on vous a vu dans
différents reportages vraiment avec un
équipement de la tête aux pieds de
protection que doit faire concrètement
les médecins les infirmières et les
infirmiers pour se protéger quand la
coved 19 dans cette guerre sanitaires
c'est nos soldats qui sont en première
ligne
ce sont nos médecins ce sont nos
infirmières se sont nombreux quartiers
ce sont deux aides soignantes
ce sont nos ambulanciers tout c'est tout
ses soldats nous devons les protéger au
maximum c'est le voit que nous leur
devions car ils vont se dévouer à 100%
il faut donc qu'ils sont et qu'on pêche
avec une combinaison un masque des
lunettes de protection des surchaussures
et il faut avoir suffisamment de
matériel parce que il faut renouveler ce
matériel relativement fréquemment
là c'est vraiment important qu'on
augmente la production dans certaines
usines des deux masques et d'équipements
de protection
exactement c'est une chose que les
chinois ont fait assez rapidement ils
ont réquisitionné des industries comme
l'industrie automobile et ils ont dansé
dans ses usines fabriquent et tout de
suite des masques des systèmes de tout
ce qu'il fallait pour la protection et
puis parler loin ils ont produit de plus
en plus de tests d'être fait le plein le
message est très très important à ce
moment c'est merci d'avoir partagé votre
expérience espérons que c'est
suffisamment de résonance pour limiter
le plus possible les dégâts de cette
pandémie merci beaucoup d'avoir est
terrible que tu de m'avoir donné la
parole